comment allez vous aujourd'hui je me
fait kiffer enfin cette semaine je me
fait kiffer il ya très peu de temps on a
fait une vidéo dans laquelle on
découvrait d'être marrant qui sont
arrivés lors de cours en ligne et il est
vrai à l'issue de cette vidéo je me suis
dit c'est trop marrant les cours
en ligne je veux en faire mais ce que
j'ai pas dit c'est que c'est drôle de
voir le peu de trucs marrants qui sont
arrivés dans des cours en ligne mais que
toute l'année les cours en ligne au
final ça pèse sur le moral de nos très
chers étudiants vous avez été nombreux à
me le dire et en fait c'est plutôt
logique vous êtes chez vous vous voyez
plus vos potes ya plus de contacts irl
c'est beaucoup plus dur à suivre et
ensuite ça m'a donné une idée dans cette
vidéo je vais à lier deux choses la
première c'est mon envie de participer à
des cours en ligne et la deuxième c'est
mon envie d'envoyer de la force à nos
étudiants qui sont en souffrance en fait
alors envahie de la france dans ce que
je veux dire c'est que l'on va on va
prier pour qu'il y en ait qui suivent
les vidéos et que cela fasse plaisir que
j'arrive dans le court je dis ça parce
que s'il y en a qui me reconnaissent pas
et qui suivent pas les vidéos baïse s'en
bat les couilles que j'arrive dans le
colle donc désolé auprès de cela je vais
juste perturbé votre court et ça vous
faire chier mais les autres j'espère que
ça fera plaisir c'est une idée que j'ai
eue j'en ai fait part à lorraine et
c'est elle qui s'est chargé de débauche
et finalement des professeurs des écoles
qui ont accepté d'être complice de ça
cette semaine je vais avoir des heures
de cours et je vais rejoindre des cours
en ligne tous les jours déjà je suis
curieux ça fait six ans que j'ai pas vu
un cours et en plus j'ai jamais vu de
cours de fac en fait de pour après le
bac je sais pas quoi faire savoir je
suis un peu stressé parce que j'ai un
grand respect pour les professeurs et
j'ai trop envie de gâcher la surprise ou
d'avoir un comportement inapproprié ou
quoi que ce soit je suis excité effrayer
c'est généralement ce qui donne des
vidéos sympas seipati premier jour de
cours à demain
chomette a reçu un lien intime ce qui
donne vers un cours ok alors ce n'est
pas n'importe quel cours car il s'agit
d'un cours de communication
événementielle avec madame bouvy madame
bouvy donc c'est un complice csssae cern
ces derniers courent la fin de l'année
et elle voulait faire une petite
surprise à ses élèves donc elle est
ravie en mode elle joue le jeu elle te
connais pas le sais pas qui tu es juste
être interroge comme un élève normal
hwa
jai ensemble c'est un vrai court et tout
tu vois ce que je dirais que oui non
mais je m'exprime trop mal j'ai pas
envie de faire des blagues ou des trucs
krine j'ai envie d'être un élève
invisible toi tu vas arriver déjà
sachent qu'il ya quarante élèves quoi
40-40 web café offert normalement tu as
le micro et désactiver tout je peux dire
que ta caméra au début dans les
premières secondes si tu veux prendre
ton temps de repérer et quand tu es prêt
tu vas à cliquer je suis une petite
icône qui dit de lever la main elle va
t'interroger tout de suite et la ta
caméra va être en grand avec tous les
élèves qui vont devoir se stresse bah
c'est le premier donc je suis écoute moi
bien bouleverser
on quitte zoom bazille à tout à tout
aussi génial les gars je suis dans la
vidéo de la dernière fois là j'ai juste
à lever la main ici et ma caméra va
s'afficher en grand je crois au milieu
tout le monde et je vais pouvoir parler
lorsque un client me demande par exemple
d'acheter pour lui des billets d'avion
les billets je les marges ou est-ce que
les billets je ne les marges par payet
apprennent à marcher tout c'est
incroyable quand on organise des choses
ok prochaine question suave chance je
suis pudique actuellement je parle plus
je me débute à temps est ce que c'est
bon micro attendait un client me dit
qu'il veut faire une exposition dans ses
bureaux à
huy en je me suis député j'ai
entendu un gars m'a parlé non
attention avait la main bonjour alors
c'est lucas bonjour
j'avais une question est ce qu'à
d'autres choses sur lesquelles il faut
pas marcher parce que c'est très visible
et on se fait prendre la main dans le
sac facilement comme pour les billets et
pour quoi ils fondent et peut-être comme
ça aussi
c'est important que mes cours soit soit
à jour
commente année vous pourrez bientôt les
cas dans notre petit cours
d'événementiel merci madame bouvy mais
c'est je suis en train de quitter le
court un premier degré je découvre ce
monde là en fait
les meuf elle a ramené son petit frère
elle a ramené son petit fils vient voir
et tout et qui j'ai une petite question
qui va être fâché qui sont les trois
meilleurs élèves là on peut le dire tout
le monde le sait je pense dans la classe
armé meilleurs élèves là en ce moment
j'ai vannes samantha marine marine où
j'adore ton et ils sont dans le col
actuellement oui bah bravo à vous
battre y en a qui font encore en
extérieur ils ont de droiture de suivre
le cours en extérieur moi tant qu'ils
sont présents s'ils sont dans leur
jardin et tout ça ne pose pas trop de
problème assez stylé c'est trop cool ça
mais d'après ce que je peux dire - lucas
ou pas vas-y marine lucas j'aime tout ce
que tu fais tu doit l'entendre depuis le
début de ta carrière mais juste ses fins
continue parce que tu donnes que
l'énergie est vraiment c'est fou bah
merci beaucoup duré bien mais ça fait
plaisir elle a ramené souffrir l'autre
regarder il apparaît
il est
hélas il a disparu d'un coup genre bon
en tout cas trop content d'avoir été
dans ce petit col et merci vraiment
madame bouvy pour cette coopération
incroyable pense qu'ils s'en
souviendront toute leur vie du dernier
cours avec moi ah ah ah ah ah madame
bovary ou feraient partie de ses proches
dont on parle toute sa vie à bientôt oui
car bientôt merci beaucoup beaucoup
retiens tout le monde merci beaucoup
le rêve j'ai fait une bangui j'ai fait
la même le même truc que les cons dans
la vidéo de moi je croyais que ça allait
me faire un test micro de ces que
j'allais parler m'entendre pour voir si
mons on mange bien pas du tout ça fait 1
devant toute la classe
juste
c'est à dire georges tin supplie du café
pas de manif débile c'est pas de la mer
et la fnac ou tiff et wahaha
la preuve vient de m'envoyer c'était
super merci petit et moi j'y compte en
est mais madame bovy représente quand
même elle est incroyable j'ai adoré
bravo leur aide pour ce premier cours
c'était une merveilleuse mise en bouche
j'ai hâte de mon prochain cours de ma
roue et on tourne cette vidéo sur une
semaine du coup parce que c'est super
dur de trouver des cours et surtout de
trouver des complices capables de nous
mettre en lien avec un prof qui est
chaud pour facettes cette petite
surprise et tout mais bon lorraine elle
s'est démenée on a quand même plusieurs
cours donc je serai content donc voilà à
demain pour le prochain coup
[Musique]
comment ça va lorraine ça va et toi tout
va bien je me suis couché très tôt
target j'ai bien dormi pour secours
cette fois ci ça se voit que tu élevé
depuis au moins de bonheur quoi alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec monsieur
rôle qui va nous faire un cours de
communication interpersonnelle alors la
communication interpersonnelle c'est un
peu par exemple pour se préparer un
entretien d'embauché pas besoin pourquoi
tu m'as mis ce cours-là de
chez c'est pas ça peut peut-être td je
vais aller sur le court là et vient de
finir de faire l'appel donc tu vas
pouvoir y aller je préviens notre
complice qu'on arrive monsieur le rôle
j'arrive je vais vous rendre fiers
monsieur et pourtant je suis fatigué
croyez moi regardez-moi les charismes de
notre cokeliss monsieur roll ça se voit
que c'est un bon professeur c'est marqué
sur sa tête et il faut justement capter
l'attention de son interlocuteur dès le
début de l' échange ou dans les
premières secondes à l'oral et aussi
dans les premières lignes elle écrit
très sens qui est dit saint des saints
sketches comme dans les lettres de
motivation ou dans les uns trop de
vidéos youtube capter la teinture l'a
dit tout de suite à la fin il se passe
un truc de dingue à cette vidéo rester
jusqu'au bout c'est la fin pour moi le
père prend souvent le politique va
parler du bilan du parti adverse pour
mettre en avant tient le bref or il est
vraiment en train de regarder cours en
fait il va participer d'être absorbé
hockey support justice hadopi c'est mon
tour
9-13 qui vaut faire en fit banques moi
je veux pierre
bon mais je sais pas ce qu'il y'a un
truc pour mais oui c'est maintenant jean
vaujour c'est pierre dupont bonjour à
tous et apprécions
le rôle qu'elle professeur incroyable tu
peux juste confiance quidome aux causes
qui font qu'aujourd'hui comme des coûts
oui j'ai une question j'ai appliqué tous
ses conseils lors d'un entretien
d'embauché pour micromania ça n'a pas
marché j'ai tout appliqué à la lettre ça
n'a pas marché donc monsieur l'euro si
vous le voulez bien j'aimerais pouvoir
venir plus fréquemment dans vos cours
pour apprendre finalement beaucoup ici
on vous tue je sais plus quoi tune bien
jean rondeau 3d qui sont costauds ma
guise de vente ira au bout si c est le
petit frère
1h40 qui ferait trop mignon comme
lorsqu'il fogarasy c'est que ce corps
n'est pas encore comme les autres
d'abord c'est néfaste et un bal des
publications du monde il faut le
rappeler est ce groupe-là
particulièrement dans les étapes en
entendrons partiellement exceptionnel je
m'éclate avec eux je sais ce que ces
processus c'est quelque chose que vous
aimez vous n'aurez vraiment l'impression
de travailler avec nos jours n'est
jamais un prêt sans travailler c'est
juste le dire monsieur le rôle voilà il
a fait appel bah écoutez merci merci de
m'avoir accueilli monsieur le rôle et
vous êtes très sympathique cette vague
que vous avez je laime je m'en inspirer
pour mes vidéos je vais essayer d'être
c'est un paquebot merci à vous comme
tout le monde merci monsieur le roch
mais monsieur le rôle mais c'est
fou c'est une tueriie monsieur le rôle
auquel orange à un cours de quoi là
aujourd'hui c'est de l'écriture
journalistique hockey et comment il
s'appelle le prof messieurs 2 mais il ya
tellement lorraine tu as vu
vient dans le col et donne toi un autre
nom et mutoi bien mais pataca maintenant
tu vas foule spoiler à huy pour ça je
vais être mort de rire sans rigoler
direct
tout à fait oui ça vaut le coup de
regarder mais j'ajoute qu'il vaut mieux
le faire lire à un tiers - lesquin qui
ont dit qu'est ce que tu en penses c'est
là où on a quand même des indications
plus nette de la perfectibilité de
l'article absolument
permet
souvent de sava l'écueil orelsan termine
c'est vraiment devenu un élève la
wii
j'ai tout ce passe t il
je peux plus aller dans ce col c'est
terminé est-ce que vous avez saisi ce
qui vient de se passer ou pas je me mute
pour parler à l'oreille de la discorde
et lui dire tout le monde s'en fout que
je met ma came alors que je ne suis
clairement pas un élèves de cette classe
donc ça me fait rire et et lawrence
c'est même
la
chine d'un cri douche tu es plus alcool
mais non j'ai quitté le zoom et l
orange il écoute moi bien écoute moi
tout le monde
mais jamais de ma vie je vais dans un
cours là c'est terminé tu regardes créé
un traumatisme dzeko et la fois
tournaisis étudie promettant avec les
achetant subi et pourquoi tu mets ça sur
mon dos droit d'asile t'inquiète
expliqué toi c'est toi qu'a fait la
bêtise j'y retourne je vais sauver ça
regardez le directeur d'école n'est pas
content de ce qui s'est passé tout à
rater vérifier l'information mais ça
veut dire commune qui suit plusieurs
sources ont parfois manquant je vous lis
j'ai envie de dire mais nous tiennent
sadou etienne ça qu'il ya dix ans ok je
vais intervenir moi j'ai fait l'erreur
sur le pyramid c'est bien ça
oui il ya quelqu'un au fonds vert qui
voudraient interagir merci bonjour
absolument un jour lucas bonjour bonjour
monsieur j'avais une question si on a
par exemple trois quatre sources mais
qu' elles concordent parfaitement mais
quelles informations sont fausses à quel
point on est en tort du coup en tant que
journaliste qui avait quatre ou cinq
sources sont fausses absolument par
malchance toutes les sources qu'on avait
on dit la même chose mais ce truc là
étaient faux ah bon alors là on entre
dans le débat très contemporain le cas
les faits qui nous a tant il paraît
parfois que les gens voient par exemple
qui viennent s'incruster comme ça dans
les dents les cours des étudiants bombes
soit par exemple c'est pas une chèque
news
ces très beaux rebondissements
incroyables attendait il faut que je
remette sur un événement parce que
lorraine elle était dans le col tout à
l'heure je vais à se masquer la main
tendue mais elle a dit devant tournée
l'a dit mais j'ai tout le monde s'en bat
les couilles elle a dit dans les cols
blancs tendus j'ai pleuré de rire et là
il s'en veut sachez qu'en ce moment même
elle s'en veut elle est morte de honte
donc voilà je vous présente ses excuses
non je suis désolé vraiment je suis
désolé je voulais dire à lui 0 m et du
monde s'en fout et on veut mais c'est
horrible je suis désolé ans
merci beaucoup tout le monde désolé
d'avoir coupé le court travail et bien
bon courage pour les visions chez que
c'est pas facile moi ça me fait rire
parce que j'en fais 20 minutes par jour
mais je sais que c'est un peu un peu
compliqué pour vous donc gros courage à
vous je souhaite le meilleur dans vos
études et puis au plaisir sur youtube 9
6 pouces des filles mères c'est tout le
monde ciao bon courage tout le monde
merci beaucoup l or n c'était un moment
d'anthologie et c'est le genre de truc
que tu as regardé dans la vidéo de
l'audio mais oui tu as fait le truc
qu'on dit qu'il arrive ça arrive jamais
tu l'as fait exactement lors m c'était
un grand moment je te remercie du late
la classe était bien trouvé le prof
était sympa directeur de l'école qui est
elle réussie était cool ouais je suis
content je suis content des gens nés
j'ai vu une personne qui m'ait
absolument pas dans le col regardez les
images il ya une personne écoute et bien
elle me déteste c'est sûr
mais en attendant à continuer de venir
dans deux trois cours et j'espère vous
allez un peu moins mahir que certains
élèves de
[Musique]
lorraine il est 8h30 du matin c'est pour
ça que je suis fatigué là non il est
13h30 et comment ma vie est un calvaire
depuis cours d'eau fort kraft est sorti
quel est le premier cours de la journée
management avec notre professeur didier
valentin s la balle quoi écouter on y va
parce que ce que je vais faire donc va
vous en avez l'habitude ans je vais je
vais partager mon écran un reggae mme
d'être prof m en vrai il
a ilâha illâ de petites fautes qu'est ce
que vous avez à l'écran pour l'instant
mon bureau ce sens jury mais excusez moi
c'est intéressant dans son cours il
parle des chefs à l'époque des gens donc
haut placé dans la hiérarchie d'une
entreprise via genre 50 ans et des gens
haut placés maintenant et les
différences il dit maintenant c'est un
manager c'est très différent à l'époque
c'étaient des chefs c'était beaucoup
plus tyrannique et tout c'est vachement
intéressant il suffit pas d'avoir
d'avoir les galons d'avoir le titre pour
que ça fonctionne et est ce qu'un bon
manager est un manager autoritaire
c'est un manager exigeant quand il faut
il doit être directif sans devenir
dictatorial en devenir tyrannique et
craquant et parce qu'ils hissent à messi
bascule je suis pierre dupont par contre
je je vous en prie je voulais je vous
laisse je vous laisse la main à rester
focus rester studio écoutez bien
monsieur valentin et puis je vous
souhaite le meilleur dans vos études la
connexion d'une très bonne ah bah je me
fais jugé je viens de la forge me fait
juger
merci désolé vous avoir coupé monsieur
valentin et merci à vous c'est monsieur
valentin qu'ils appuient cette surprise
à un ami chez nous là je le précise là
c'est grâce à lui
calé en présentiel en présence et voilà
ils attendaient
au courage à tous au revoir merci
ils étaient mignons bras les cours
suivants ils sont déjà là ok donc mal on
veut bien présente mais votre micro ne
fonctionne pas au ballon et on la
connaît celle là est ok j'ai
l'impression qu'à certains micro qui
sont ouverts par mois au plus tard il
m'a fait peur j'ai cru c'était moi qui
j'ai cru que j'avais fait de lorraine
c'est la fiesta il est trop stylé lui là
en bas à gauche l'arrière lui les
mannequins le type il devrait dans des
catalogues il devrait pas être dans un
cours en ligne elias est ce que vous
pouvez me rappeler qu'ils créent la
monnaie et bias elias c'est la banque
centrale qui crée c'est la banque
centrale qui créent la monnaie est ce
que tout le monde est d'accord avec ça
n'empêche pas d'accord au aussi un rap
contenders secours mais non j'ai une
vraie question pour vous et j'ai une
question existentielle c'est quoi la
monnaie comment on peut définir
ducasse et maintenant ça tombe en panne
touche à une vase y expliquer moi en
quoi la monnaie c'est quelque chose
qu'on utilise pour faire du troc
peut-être que c'est une valeur marchande
universel ce que ce terme marche
[Musique]
une valeur marchande universel
absolument on peut considérer que c'est
une valeur marchande universel hockey y
en a qui sont se caler en économie à
savoir tu connais youtube
moi j'étais à fond dans le coup mais
gage était plongé dans la musique dans
le cours d'eau y est ce que je me achoui
j'irai mais je suis venu vous donner de
la force pour vos cours les amis bonjour
quoi renvoyer la force aux étudiants
puisque c'est que c'est pas simple pour
vous actuellement ni pour les
professeurs ni pour les élèves soyez
studieux et je vous souhaite le meilleur
dans vos études
[Musique]